foreign
[Music]
good morning good morning everybody
thanks for coming
today we're going to share some of our
experiences and and talk about sort of
10 things to know about managing and
operating services in in Google Cloud
so I'm Preston Holmes I'm a product
manager in Google Cloud I've actually
been here maybe close to nine years now
and prior to that in Amazon so I've been
in the public Cloud space over a decade
and have seen and helped quite a few
customers
move from various circumstances on the
cloud and so that's my perspective on on
these 10 points and I have ROM
hey everyone good morning how are you
hope you all having a great next session
uh thanks for attending our session my
name is Ram gogrini I'm a principal SRE
architect at Charles Schwab responsible
for the entire observability strategy
and implementation uh I mean day-to-day
I work with several asari teams in
taking care about high availability of
our applications or resiliency what not
entire sorry things will be running with
all our partners
so when you look at the cloud sort of
the journey to the cloud right it's
always going to be a little bit
mysterious and I kind of make an analogy
to Parenting so any of you that are
parents know that there's simply
unknowable challenges that are in the
future and that you're never going to be
prepared ultimately for the challenges
that come you simply need to be adaptive
and respond and learn as you go and and
this is true of the cloud journey I
think most organizations uh set out
thinking they are going to make a plan
and that the plan will in advance take
care of every sort of foreseeable thing
but the truth is it's still a very large
and very complicated process but
documentation the training all these
things help but at the end of the day
there's going to be no substitute for
the uniqueness of your journey
yeah as I said I'm from Charles Schwab
here is a little bit about uh Schwab and
who is Schwab what swap does
and uh yeah I'd like to you know take to
what person is saying about the cloud
journey is complicated definitely it is
complicated but you know the more you
start doing into the journey right you
know with the best principles and all
that stuff it gets better and currently
Schwab runs a variety of critical
workloads uh you know that ranging from
data to already gke workloads anything
there are several workloads running
Cloud uh however you know as we started
initially the journey will be tough uh
like any other thing as it involves
several stakeholders you know from your
development team QA networking everybody
the first thing is making sure everybody
is onboarded to the same Mission okay
everybody together on this journey and
also
uh in the strategy making sure you're
identifying the right application uh for
the migration on the beginning from the
application identification all the way
to your last my love how do you uh you
know Obama migrate from either from data
center or from other Cloud partner to
the complete the last mile so that's
where first you need to buy in the
entire stakeholders also I mean don't
assume that your first architectural
blueprint or document would be the one
that is going to the production right as
part of the journey you need to review
and see what are the trade-offs between
the applications what needs to be done I
mean for example you know nowadays all
these uh microservices run either on you
know if you want going in gcp you may
choose to run either Cloud run or gke
you may start with Cloud run and then
you know depends on the workload not
necessarily you don't have to go to gke
but Cloud run so the whole point is you
got to be flexible be agile and learn as
you go on the ability to change your
stuff so on the Fly that will enable you
to accept the strategy you write and
have a methodical approach on how entire
migration it could be a data it could be
you know application stack everything
need to be together for a successful
Cloud migration Journey
today as part of that I came here to
share uh some of the learnings for one
of our the critical application we
hosted in gcp is called a client
authentication application
we have a suite name called cake okay
client authentication in Cloud
so what it does is you know the
authentication uh
it authenticates a multi-millions of
logins every month
and it has a several you know based on
the workloads right he has a peak if you
look at some of the retailers they may
have uh Peaks during the holiday season
and yesterday I attended a papasanth
talk they're talking about Freddy's are
their peaks right Friday evenings are
their Peak however for swab every day
the morning during the market open and
evening of the market close those are
our Peak workloads so we got to be ready
to support what are the peak we are
getting so that's one of the reason you
know for the agility elasticity also the
scaling we chose gke as our core
application architecture and our ability
to run you know across the workloads in
multi region set up and all that stuff I
would like to spend a little bit more on
this diagram which has more inferences
in you know of the topic
if you look at here uh the entire gke
running in gcp there also there are as
we are in the journey uh not necessarily
uh we're able to migrate everything to
the cloud once it's a journey right some
you know still running on on-prem so we
talk to the on-prem services the data
center Services also if you look at the
down the logs
we made an architectural change in such
a way that uh given this hybrid workload
mode uh some Cloud native as well as
some on-prem we are bringing all these
logs together to gcp to take the
advantage of in the scale of gcp so that
we can get a single pane of monitoring
glass View and ability to identify the
issues quickly and all that stuff so
those are the couple of the high level
architectural points
um
this slide is very busy or slide in
reality but it's stripped up in order to
show the high level stuff so yeah
great
so we're going to now kind of talk about
10 things and these aren't we we
actually the original title of this talk
was the top 10 things and we took the
word top out right because we're not
going to presume to rank and order these
These are 10 things that in our
conversations we thought would be
something interesting to share about
some aspect of what we've learned
matters or doesn't matter in this and
we're going to take sort of a a format
to each of these things and what it'll
start with is just a general quick
statement of what the topic is and and
in in sort of a cloud vendor agnostic
way all right then I'll try to talk a
little bit about what I see as some of
Google Cloud's
opinions or best practices or maybe some
of the lesser-known elements again it
won't be comprehensive we're not going
to cover each of these topics to their
Nth Degree and then Ron will talk a bit
about Schwab's own opinions at a
company-wide level as a cloud
organization how they look at that topic
and then we'll use that application he
just described to talk about how
particular decisions get made all the
way down sometimes at that application
by application Level
so the first is going to be resource
hierarchy now any Cloud vendor is going
to be largely infrastructure via apis
right it's an API driven system and
these apis create resources these
resources are always grouped or bound
together into some sort of containment
system these might be workspaces or
projects or folders
in some places they might be just by
account so how these Cloud resources are
organized and grouped together is
usually something that is deeply
ingrained into the way any given Cloud
vendor presents its products and these
choices that you make about how you
organize your company's usage of cloud
in that resource hierarchy is often a
very sort of permanent and foundational
decision in other words it's not
something you easily want to go back and
change two years later about how you
sort of embrace a given resource
hierarchy
at gcp our resource hierarchy really
starts with a cloud organization and
most companies have a single Cloud
organization as part of their usage of
gcp there are larger companies where
they have say very large Acquisitions or
divisions that operate more as a
subsidiary where they might use multiple
cloud orgs
and then within the organization we have
folders and the folders are really just
nodes of a hierarchy they don't really
have much other than as a point of
attachment for things like policy and
then the real atom of the gcp resource
model is the project and the project is
the thing that contains a cloud resource
every cloud resource every product makes
things happen in Cloud projects and this
hierarchy is something that you can use
to attach things like policy to that
have inheritance down to the to the
lower levels of the resource hierarchy
and so how you use folders and
organizations and how you use those to
attach policy we'll talk about policy a
bit more later is really key to sort of
how you choose to use gcp
absolutely Preston now in gcp World
project is the key right all the
resources are in the project we do
follow the similar approach uh kind of
the same Approach at an org level of
folders and projects also the way our
projects or organized it's more a
business component level right business
transaction uh the same influence we can
go back to client authentication which
is made up of several logical uh
Services made up of authentication they
are all grouped into one application ID
literally we call it as a application
portfolio management based on the APM ID
the projects are created and these are
followed through all the way from
sandbox all to end QE all the way to the
production that's the approach we
followed and also everything is driven
through terraform it's easy to create a
project and the trade on a project and
at some point if I need an additional
project for do some testing right or
something else needed is kind of so one
full request you will be able to spin up
a project quickly and I am done with
that project then you can tear it down
so there is a lot of flexibility the way
how Google organizes the projects and
also the resources within the project as
well so it's very helpful
now when it comes to sort of structuring
permissions and policy you know I think
this is uh again any Cloud vendor is
going to have mechanisms and tools for
this at the end of the day this is
really about trying to find the balance
between control and sort of flexibility
and permission to be you know productive
in whatever you do and that is a
balancing act you can overdo this if you
sort of over apply overly complex
permissions and policy it can become a
burden for the workforce right but so
it's a balancing act between those two
I'd also like to kind of be you know a
little bit of a soapbox around some of
the security features in that
overly complex security setup can be a
security anti-pattern in my opinion
meaning if you have a security set up
that very few people can reason about or
make sense of that actually become
something that is very hard to monitor
whether it's doing what you want to do
and so we have in-cloud vendors many
tools and many capabilities and those
should be applied sort of in the
appropriate ways where they apply so now
in gcp we predominantly have two main
dialects around this we have IM which is
really around resource access and
permissions and that really Gates usage
of the API on the different products and
services and then we have organizational
policy and organizational policy is
really more around capturing the intent
of governance and management around
practices and guidance around how to use
products and both of those can attach to
the resource hierarchy we generally
believe that you should structure things
like permission around roles rather than
always around individuals this makes
managing the
permission of individuals easier because
you're talking about membership of a
group rather than having to kind of keep
track of individual policies of I am
applied to individuals
um
lastly you know there's always going to
be some choice about that shared
responsibility with the gcp as a
customer so for example we do offer many
managed security features that I think
are advantageous for Outlet to let
Google do sort of the management of
security things like keys but we do
allow you to do things like bring your
own Keys through customer managed
encryption keys and this is all about
picking some choice you have on a trust
boundary with Google so you may trust
Google more to manage keys or if you
want to do more of the key management
yourself and take more of that burden on
you can use something like the the
customer manage encryption key so those
are all choices you need to make around
an adoption of a security model with the
cloud vendor because it'll always be a
shared responsibility model
thank you so you know if you are into
the very early stages of the
gcp interval the IAM could be
overwhelming and daunting you know it's
very confusing also to start with you
know what are the different permissions
needs to be applied which groups you
know layers and all that stuff
you know after a while they definitely
once you get a hang of you know then you
know exactly how these are works but the
best practice is you know we do follow
also you know industry level will be the
ad groups uh based on the project you
may need a different groups of users
right you know some could be in need
only the viewer role access some could
be the editor role suppose a security
team or a team they need only the viewer
access right all these managed via the
ad groups now the groups has you know
required people suppose you know 4q
people will be one group a developer
will be another one sret will be in
another group so that's why you set up
your own group and also create the
appropriate roles in that group that way
you know you have the right roles set up
in that group one other thing you know
we truly believe that the the privilege
of least privileged access for any group
right you don't need then what is truly
needed to perform that job so just want
to make sure uh the required permissions
least privilege access is given to any
group so that you know the entire
security posture can be managed very
well
so we're going to talk about quotas now
quotas are not anyone's favorite thing
in general I think quotas are something
that in systems now we have quotas
internally internal systems all the
Google all also use quotas this is not
something just externalized in sort of a
cloud services space and they're really
to protect everyone from unforeseen
usage at the end of the day I think the
key thing with quotas is to be proactive
and and in their management and not be
reactive when you start running into
issues now that means being familiar
with the nature of them because
different quota systems apply to
different products using different kind
of measurements of a window so some
quotas are sort of based on a pure
absolute number other quotas are more
time based so being familiar with each
product you're using in the nature of
the quotas in gcp many quotas are
actually Auto approved based on your own
sort of usage of cloud if you're if
you're sort of a good uh like
long-standing user of cloud and you're
paying your bills Etc you have
essentially a lot of your quotas will be
Auto approved other quotas do require
human review
and it's important for you to monitor
the consumption of quotas so that you
can be proactive ahead of the time they
might come up now the final thing I'll
say is that any significant large
project like you know when we're dealing
with a very large retailer around Black
Friday or broadcast around a major
sporting event these always sort of will
require some degree of conversation with
an account team we often set up very
collaborative sort of uh you know a
large event management teams to make
sure we're doing the right kind of load
testing and capacity planning Etc so the
the day-to-day usage of quotas is sort
of one thing around this sort of ongoing
proactive measurement and then I'll say
special events require special attention
and that's absolutely something we do
thanks Preston and always the quotas are
you know an interesting topic so on how
these will play a role so um I think uh
you know the in the early stages of your
development and all right you should be
able to identify what is the truly
required quota for each service for your
critical workloads in production suppose
you know I may be I need to run these
many logins per minute in that right so
that what are the different things we
need to be making sure maybe the logging
API you know bigquery or any VMS or GK
right all these quotas do play a role
and if you go to the Google Cloud
console there are 13 300 or something
services available where you can
configure the quotas so it is very hard
to know right which one to pick which 10
I need to set the quotas the way we plan
was and we did was in our lower
environment when you run this uh the
performance test that's how you know
right what is the scale you need to run
this application then you run the
performance test and to the scale what
you needed and go back and look at your
quotas right okay where are my quotas
around this also you may put some
threshold about that I always like to
know when my quotas are approaching
around 70 or 80 percent and then create
an alert on top of those right that way
also there are a better dashboards
available for quota management as well
but the key is identifying the required
quota
I can take a couple of examples you know
real life where we you know see it and
also later we found it for example if we
take the bigquery and bigquery has the
uh as by default there is no it has
unlimited uh data query for a day right
there is no limited bigquery usage per
day I mean one way it is good so that
you know is Nothing is Stopping but
really not sure right unless say like
you have hundreds of users each one is
using to an extent then that will add up
your quota so and also there is one more
level deep uh deeper there is a bigquery
usage per user per day say like you have
100 users each one is using like 100
terabytes then that will quickly add up
right so depends on the use case what
you're trying to do you may want to
clearly look into the quotas for each
service and configure appropriately that
way uh accidentally you won't run into
uh impose your application stopping your
app location in the middle of doing
something or you know adding more cost
to it so always quotas needs to be
reviewed monitored and alerted that way
you have right way to manage them
foreign
we'll talk now about log management so
logging is obviously probably the the
oldest form of application monitoring I
mean everyone who starts development
starts with some level of print
debugging and those become logs and then
logs become more sophisticated over time
there's never been more logging as there
is today and I think each day that
becomes a you know an equally true
statement
so not only is there more logs being
generated from more sources but logs are
changing in their nature so one is that
logs are increasingly highly structured
and structured logs provide a much
richer source of information about the
systems that they are logging
also logs are becoming increasingly
useful Beyond Simple operations so logs
have a lot of information that are
increasingly relevant to the business
and the products that they're associated
with and so
you know the origins of bigquery in many
ways at Google were about our internal
logging problem how do we manage logs at
scale at Google when you had the first
sort of iterations of Google where we
were getting into hundreds of thousands
of servers and so in Google we do have a
lot of Tools around centralizing and
storing logs and that's often our
recommendation ROM has done a lot in
this space I'm going to let ROM talk
more about what Schwab's done all right
thank you president you might need to
warn me now either logging or
troubleshooting I will keep going and
talking for hours
so definitely logging yeah you know it's
a very interesting topic um
as you start running your workloads it
produces various types of logs system
logs application logs networking logs
VPC logs right you got to be real
understanding what are the different
logs that's coming to your project and
what is the true needed logs needs to be
in your project first identify the logs
suppose your application is chatty it is
that I am writing so many logs you may
not have enough time to fix it but
however the way you would do is you know
once it comes to the project you know
from the log sync you can drop the logs
or unwanted logs so first key is
identify the required logs if you take
about the VPC logs you know it has tons
of logs obviously they do some rate of
sampling even on top of it it produce
tons of logs so if you are not careful
about it you know slow it will faster
add up your log buckets will increase
also it will add up so much of cost as
well so first key is identify the
required logs uh then drop The Unwanted
logs not even
second one is how do you manage your log
life cycle okay I know what are the logs
I need it to be then how do you keep
them right you know maybe there are
different purposes for these logs one
could be for operational for
troubleshooting some may need a lifetime
of either 30 days or 60 days that is the
default Google provider 60 day in in the
cloud console and later maybe for
various reasons could be for audit
purpose or for the analytical reasons
and all you may want to find the target
state of these logs some can go to GCS
some may go to bigquery if you chose the
route for GCS for audit purpose or
something then you need to identify what
is the long term strategy right do I
need to bring them very often or it can
go to the cold storage versus near time
real bucket and all that stuff also
uh if uh the the policy of your sorting
the logs is more of an analytical reason
bigquery would play a greater role here
especially you can store them also bring
as needed with some other analytical
tools on top of it so you know when we
did some comparison right you know I
think with the big bigquery comparison
available and all that stuff the cost
also in a GCS and uh bigquery there is
not much of a a difference so you can
use that as well uh also
now one other thing I would like to talk
about is you know all these uh micro
Services they may span across the
projects so then on your services is in
one project and you are consuming few
other services across the project then
how do you get the common visibility
into these projects
so the approach we took was you know
creating the a common logging project
where all the logs would go to one
centralized lightning project that way
yeah you would have an access to the
projects also those logs can be
controlled via the log views uh suppose
a project a not necessarily having
access to the other logs in the project
however they may sum this can be
controlled via the IIM permissions log
views also you would be able to
restrict some of the logs even at a log
field level restriction as well so that
way logs plays a critical role in this
entire Cloud migration journey and all
so definitely a lot of thought needs to
be put in place for proper log
management and life cycle of it
thanks
now closely related to to sort of
logging in the soft space is
troubleshooting one of the challenges
often in in a in a cloud platform in
troubleshooting is you do have limited
visibility into the internals of some of
the systems you're using right so it's
often important to recognize that if
something is going wrong sometimes the
first place you need to check is the
vendor status dashboard right because it
might be that there's a a product level
outage or something degraded now I will
admit something the way any vendor is
exposing something on their status
dashboard is based on a threshold and
because products don't simply go offline
always in an All or Nothing way you
often have degraded conditions in a
cloud service that do not make it to the
status dashboard because you might have
a condition where you have say four
percent of customers who happen to be in
this part of a data center who happen to
be trying to do one operation on that
product or hitting an issue right that
kind of degradation usually doesn't rise
up to a status dashboard and that can be
frustrating if you were seeing a problem
but it's not listed on a status thing
and that's really where if if you have
the support team and you have the
connection with support support can look
into your projects and your resources
and help clarify whether you might be
being impacted by what is sort of a sub
threshold condition Within product so
know that that is that is one option
sort of beyond the status dashboard if
you have the right kind of support tier
when it comes to understanding the root
cause I really just sort of want to use
this moment to be a proponent of
distributed tracing right when you have
complex data paths going through
multiple Cloud products in your own
potentially multiple Cascade of
microservices and you're seeing an end
condition of hey we're seeing a really
slow response times why
asking that question why is this certain
service slow is usually about decide or
Drilling in and figuring out which part
of the 12 to 15 things it might be doing
is potentially most contributing to that
slowness and distributing distributed
tracing while it does take a pretty
significant investment to put in place
to instrument the code is by far one of
the best ways to see
where in this call Path latency might be
introduced
thanks Preston for our deep insights uh
yeah troubleshooting is uh my daily uh
one of my favorite topic so
and as you said right depend in the
initial day itself our architecture uh
given we have workloads running hybrid
workloads uh Cloud native as well as you
know some to the on-prem as well the
architectural choice we made was to
bring all the logs into gcp to take the
advantage of our scale of gcp so then we
are having all of our logs uh including
our our logs AS application logs as the
correlation IDs all that stuff
everything is in one central place now
which is in the gcp cloud operations in
the log buckets analyticals and bigquery
so the key idea here is how quickly you
can identify the issue like you know the
quicker mttd and mttr those are the key
things right the you should have an
ability to for your SRE teams and
quickly identify the detect the issue
and the ability to take an action so
that you can restore the system quickly
so the approach we follow you know kind
of from several years uh we are doing
the same thing our data center as well
the same principles were being applying
each of our critical or any service we
monitor those sres Google and signals
latencies traffic errors and saturation
rate and we built our SRE team did a
phenomenal job in building several
dashboards you know which has these
golden signals and the approach we took
was is kind of a three layer we have
these business metrics application
metrics and infrastructure metrics maybe
let's take a step back what are the
business metrics why do we need that one
okay your entire system is built to do a
business function is it really doing
what is supposed to doing so uh yet at
any given point of time I'm interested
in how my authentication app is working
how many logins it is authenticating are
how quick it is doing and what is the
peak rate how can I go back and look
back what is my yesterday's login rates
compared to Prior week or something
right these are all the different
business metrics we should be able to
bring it back to your dashboard and then
if we go another level is the
application metric in order to provide
that business value how my application
is performing uh what is the latency
each user is experiencing how are the
error rates are working or you know in
any other creation is happening in the
application those are all driven through
the application dashboards and one more
level is the infrastructure
that's where the saturation comes in a
CPU memory error rates and all that
stuff so to get into one common view
with all these three metrics and give a
quick view for any SRE engine needs or
our
command level control people like you
know able to quickly identify and then
you know take next steps so we built
several log based metrics given we are
bringing all the logs into the gcp uh
entire gcp is driven off of the metrics
several log based metrics were built
which ported to the dashboards and each
dashboard or in the metric is tied to an
SLO which has internally has slis and
all that stuff so given through this
slower monitoring also you know the
critical alerts are created which will
go to our level one Command Center and
all that stuff you know create a
directly paging and all that stuff so in
in that I know we have an ability to uh
you get a lot of alerts sometimes you
know when you are into the early stages
of the journey especially when you
changing the monitoring tools right
suppose you know you have the on-prem
have one tool and then move to the gcp
you may using different tools also in
the beginning days of Journey you may
put more threshold ranges that way you
know you are monitoring sometimes there
could be aggressive sometimes you know
little more relaxed so there will be a
lot of noise in the alerts to begin with
but you got to be you know looking to
the carefully and you know soon adjust
those alert threshold that way you have
the right alert signal to face able to
do quick actionable and don't want to
get caught into the uh you know alert
noise or alert fitting all that stuff
that's another thing helping us also you
know I want to give credit to the Google
team as well in the last two years
there's a lot of improvements done in
the Google Cloud operation suit
especially the logs Explorer also the
log analytics is the one which is still
growing but you know there are a lot of
features coming in the log analytics
where you don't need to really go into
the bigquery but from the logs console
itself ability to do the queries as well
and uh all of our logs today they go to
bigquery as well for analytical purpose
too and we do use the log sync to get
that one but however you know given
there are some challenges you know the
way how you the logs will go to the from
the log Explorer to the bigquery
it will identify the first record sets
the schema some of the issues with
challenges so log analytics is the one
solving those so with the combination of
you know the planet scale of some of
these Google tools and the great work
from our SRE team with the principles of
what we're adhering to helping us to
troubleshoot the issue and able to you
know run this scale of application the
critical application without any
incidents and all that stuff
all right we're gonna say a few things
about cost management and and I'll start
with saying that cost management
continues to be difficult on the cloud I
think first and foremost this is really
because the models in the way cloud is
built for largely in these sort of
metered and consumption-based patterns
is very different from the way most
companies Finance systems operate in
terms of procurement and budgeting and
planning and so there's there's a lot of
things that
um you know when moving applications to
the cloud means adopting to how you're
going to plan forecast and model the
cost of given application which may have
many many dimensions across different
parts of the cloud such as network
storage
Etc
one of the key things in terms of how we
see companies modernizing the way they
approach cost management is to really
adopt this process of finops
um this idea of operating and automating
more of the way you manage and monitor
and analyze costs right so in gcp one
thing that has been a good practice for
a long time is to use tagging on
resources that you can use the way of
aggregating resource billing to
particular projects or business units
Etc so tagging is extremely useful also
all of our billing data when we've been
talking about the types of logging and
analytics you can do is also exportable
to bigquery right for where you can
build dashboards
Etc and then finally I'll just say that
when when building
complex applications on cloud there's
really almost no substitution for
running the load tests of what it would
look like to actually run the
application and then using that as a
snapshot to do an approximation of what
your billing will be at a given sort of
usage of volume
yeah thank you definitely costs you know
we got to be really cognizant about what
kind of workloads you're running in
cloud and how they are running and also
why they are running right now
especially in the early stages of you
know we're still in that uh on-prem data
center maybe how many of you can recall
the last time when you I'm a
decommissioned a server because you are
not really in use right I mean we let it
go are it's not our problem somebody
will take care about you know
decommission the server because we are
not paying and somebody else is not
paying right so here you got to be
really understanding about what are the
workloads running why they are running
how they are running have you know
complete monitoring on those uh Google
has a good way to monitor uh you know
the cost as well based on the skus your
components using how much is the
bigquery compute and all that stuff also
if needed there are third party tools as
it supports with the billing API and all
you're able to get into one common place
if you have to come here with the
on-prem versus all these costs the way
how I feel is you know once you onboard
to any public Cloud it's like you're
getting into
a you know olderness taxi which is
running a meter on right unless as you
are on the car the meter keep running he
can't sit on the car and forget right
similarly you have to you know keep
tracking and what is running and the
ability to most of the time you start
your development in a sandbox or
something and you move on you may not
necessarily stop it he keeps adding on
it so
also you know you may start running some
workloads in production maybe how to
really analyze and observe it do you
truly need it to run that scale or
something or there are opportunities to
optimize like you know schedule scaling
versus pre-scaling
um you know sometimes need a peak load
at a certain point of time the rest of
the day would be very normal you may not
need it so all these things needs to be
considered you got to remember
everything what you're running or plan
to run has a cost to it nothing is free
in Cloud
that's good
all right so this one is sort of an
interesting grab bag and that is that in
in adopting Cloud architectures there's
often going to be trade-offs in your
application in other words people often
say they want you know the lowest
latency with the highest durability with
the you know the greatest degree of
resiliency but there are trade-offs in
the way you design these systems and
sometimes they require balance I think
it's always important to make these
choices based on your users experience
whether that's an internal user or an
external user in other words there are
some experiences that don't require the
fastest latency you know do you need
something to be responsive within 100
milliseconds if it's a batch data
processing job probably not
in this area when it comes to resiliency
one important thing in gcp is to
recognize that different products have
different sort of geographic default uh
distributions in the way they are
managed so there are some Cloud
resources which are inherently zonal
some that are Regional and some that are
multi-regional and so as you're building
your system recognizing which model each
product is sort of adopted in the way
it's automatically managing resiliency
is important that you kind of don't
build a system that say uses three
regional components and one zonal
component because now your whole system
is going to be only as resilient as its
least resilient component
um
yeah thank you person I would like to
spend just a quick thing on the
resiliency so the way how we approach
this was uh I mean the based around the
criticality of our application right
internally we have an operational risk
rating uh all our apps are categorized
you know what is the risk or you know
the critical application and all based
around that or architecture is said okay
you need to run in a multi-region you
know multi-zonal setup that way you
would be able to at any given point of
time our goal is to be able to solve
this application the peak loads from a
single region are also within a single
zone so I mean that way you know we are
fault all right you know unless it is
truly needed we don't want to go to you
know the Dr Zone all this something in
some cases you have a you know a
multi-region workloads also running you
know active active some could be you
know active on warm standby all that
stuff but the goal here is you know you
have a resiliency built into it at a
regional level also at a Zona level
ability to support the workload
so um we'll move along pretty quickly I
think we've got a few more to come yeah
so the this one is really just to
recognize that when you are moving from
a traditional environment to the cloud
that data and the choices in databases
and things like that are really wide and
open right I think a lot of systems in
the past have assumed that there's a
database and that's going to be a
one-size-fits-all database and all
applications are built on that database
in the cloud you have many choices when
it comes to data and really a single
application might use multiple database
systems depending on the particular user
journey within that application that is
being served so my point here is to sort
of embrace that recognize that different
facets of an application might benefit
from different types of data products
and to pick the right one for the right
job within an application
yeah I totally agree you know we did the
same thing you know based around the
true need and use case we adopted you
know to the data diversity and all you
know several databases also caching
components all that stuff also for
analytics we use the bigquery there is
one of the way you know based on the
need in the past you know our analytics
are done in the monitoring tool now they
are moved to you know the planet scale
bigquery that's where you take you know
available product and the approach as
needed
so
um as as a as a company is embracing a
cloud the cloud itself becomes this very
vast source of information both from an
analytics point of view as well as an
operational
um like event driven point of view so
many of the cloud products and Cloud
systems like I had mentioned that
billing itself can generate queries ROM
has talked about things like VPC logs
these all provide a lot of information
in the way you're using the cloud and
and should be analyzed the same way your
application is analyzed for performance
the other thing is that in gcp we have a
system called event Arc which is
generating events for every audited log
and in the future this will actually be
generating events for almost any API
operation and so
automating and sort of treating this as
a programmable Cloud itself is a great
way to adopt maybe new types of
architectures that you may not even yet
be adopting in your application such as
event-driven architectures
doing that for your Cloud operations is
a great place to become more effective
and more efficient in the way you're
using cloud
there are several opportunities
available you know to take the advantage
of the truly the Automation Way right
you know each event driven you know then
do something something right you know
it's all kind of you know to keep your
system in up to date all that stuff also
uh taking the opportunities say for
example we have you know all of our data
is coming to bigquery including you know
metrics uh how the system is performing
the one thing we are looking at is you
know how do you know Cloud provide us to
run the cloud right you know the
capacity on Demand right capacity it's
called how to identify the required
capacity so since the data is in
bigquery we are exploring how to do some
of these models like the standard arima
model or the battery categorization
model or something that should tell us
what is the capacity I needed to run my
application for the next week versus
next month or the peak loads and all
that stuff
there's a lot to come under front
and finally we have um how to learn
effectively you know we talked at the
beginning that the cloud journey is
always going to involve extensive
amounts of ongoing learning so a few of
sort of the things I've pulled out to
talk about here is one really make sure
at Google Cloud you can learn a lot
about the way all products work by
learning about the way we design and
build apis so we've got a lot of public
documentation about things like grpc
protocol buffers and even our own
API design guidelines are publicly
published so kind of learning that once
gives you a lot of learning of all
current and future products at gcp the
second is make sure your teams have the
ability and freedom to learn and
experiment you have to be able to
experiment to learn the way a product
works to make sure people have access to
things like test projects and
experimental projects you know support
hackathons and fun things to do to try
new things with new Cloud products in
your organization and lastly as somebody
who's now actually involved in the the
duet a myself I'll say you know take
advantage of AI to help assist summarize
and find answers to problems when and
where you need them because you can lose
a lot of time you know switching out of
what you're doing to go chase down a set
of documentation and we're really trying
to make AI something that can bring the
answer of what you need to know at the
place you need to know it
I agree learning plays a critical role
in any Cloud Journey unless your
resources are really learned and know on
where they are need to operate right
otherwise it's very hard in the journey
so as president mentioned there are
several Google resources available great
documentation a dollar per blocks uh
also the
the case studies from the customers
right if somebody's already figured out
how to run a gke at scale probably you
don't need to spend so much of cycles of
time or get an abstract and see how you
can apply to that and also another thing
is you know a learning entire gcp it
holistically helps then you know
learning it small bits of it uh one
thing our leadership encouraged slash
mandated was you know everybody in the
project you know ability to get the
certification yeah the cloud engineer or
gcp certification all that stuff that
also helped us
I myself got like two certifications
last year on that path so that's really
one you know good way to learn and take
progress into the next things
all right with that thank you all for
coming yeah
yeah so I would like to take one last
minute you know as I said the cloud
journey is definitely very complicated
it takes a mountain of people you know
to run this so I would like to take you
know uh one quick minute to thank each
and everyone from our swap team uh
including from our executive management
leadership we have our great architects
in place if you are our management is
already here you know with all the helps
from all the teams we are able to
complete this migrated this critical
application I'm just happened to be one
here but there is an army of people
behind this to making its very
successful thank you excellent we're out
of time where we are available in the
hallway if anyone has any questions
thank you so much
foreign